ah this Friday this Friday
Brendan sobs Showtime special I think
you'd be surprised just watch you got a
too much or die your fan of this show
then watch his Showtime special
otherwise you know what we don't accept
you as a [ __ ] fan there is a family
either and by the way it you get 30 days
of free show time if you watch it yeah
so tune in tune in and and tweet along
you know what I mean I'm sure and if you
tuned in Chris will come to your house
is on a private show yes he okay so this
is not true I knew it was nothing she'd
be more supportive his friend I am
supportive I do think you should watch
it and I'm going to watch if I'm not
gonna show up live but you should watch
Brendan jobs you should be surprised
Friday night I believe it's no dope
given my phone number alright well
anyway let's start the shelf but it's
yeah 7:00 p.m. is your Friday 7:00 p.m.
Friday what and promo code shop for for
what for for Showtime no 30 days free
all right bye-bye
cool well guys it's Chris Delia no it's
better still II a day no but much oh oh
that's dumb the way it started on you
get a phone call Oh a professional is it
a [ __ ] thing no first of all this is
too small the end table is too small
it's not big it's not [ __ ] heavy
enough so when you move the microphone I
take with it cuz I don't know my own
strength
but that's what they're saying about me
now right it's not only strength nobody
saying that all right you seen your
underwear in front of you know millions
hundreds and thousands millions
something man
dude here we are fighter in the kid it's
the number two podcast right
congratulations we did numbers and we're
actually bigger than you guys get to
since you already listened to
congratulations this week
now this one is you're like okay well
listen to this one too I guess
no well I'm on this one as well no so
hello guys and I'm with my guest no
you're not like you're not gonna run
over Palin you're not gonna take summer
so everybody knows you as Chris D'Elia
and alia that's what I'm saying so for
you guys who who say them Chris Delia
guy what's that Christy Leah got like
Julia they don't say that right they
don't say that I know most a couple of
name a couple of things I want to say we
performed last night okay and I have
pointers for you so that was
was better right so no is out but that's
what they were all like you're better
than him we went and I went well he
didn't really have time cuz he got
thrown off by the crowd cuz he has he
got thrown off no I didn't you went who
went first who won first Mir you I
forget I went first so that's what we
call that's what we call it okay
I I was happy to have been in the lineup
and could have chosen we happy they said
Chris do you are cases from our Ireland
said yeah he said I would you mind if I
put you up first because if Chris has to
follow you then he'll be depressed if
that was marginally would be sexy but
it's not it's a [ __ ] horrible he's
got a very accent is bad yeah he looks
he's you he's the Irish Chris D'Elia
he's me if like I was on the streets for
yeah for months yeah he's you if you
came up with all like from Ireland and
you had no don't do your accents my
accents are so spot-on
let me ask you a question seriously yeah
what little boy is freezing outside
because you stole his outfit you stole
his whole outfit look at that little boy
shirt you have on dude this is the
little same oh I love all set yeah but
that shirt was a little boy shirt okay
listen
yeah it the stripes that go this way are
flattering they're a horizontal stripes
for those of you listening to this make
my was make my shoulders but it makes
Brian ring out as brought my shoulder my
shoulders for the broadness that they
actually are you kind of you look like
you're you know what you did you look
like you put on the outfit and then grow
up that's what you look like that's what
you [ __ ] look like what the [ __ ] my
future oh [ __ ] dude hey put your [ __ ] I
put my son but you brought this up yeah
cuz I want to ask you a hair had to put
it I had to put my sunglasses on so
obnoxious cuz your future so bright yeah
that's exactly yeah okay so you get it I
don't get it cuz I want to ask you
seriously I want to get I want to get
serious and I want to I want to start
reading question all right start with a
future so bright a night sucks the man I
need to wear sunglasses endorsed you
don't I want to start with this question
right let's start with the general man
ready right I'm looking at you got holes
in your jeans you guys cuz I live life I
live life I look line I know so let's
start with this number will will dilate
down you
that means I know it dilations man you
know but so I read bro you know okay but
so you read you know he read Twitter so
no no no I really know I'm gonna read
and comments but no I'm gonna read soon
your tombstone in five years cuz you oh
good well I'll be there
what's my tombstone than the saying what
are you gonna say I'm if you know what
it said honestly YouTube's I was gonna
say he tried it's gonna be dot dot dot
question mark it's gonna trail off your
tombstone hunter trail off no what are
you gonna say at my funeral I asked you
to speak I'm gonna honestly go like this
I'll speak and then I'll go on there and
then it'll be like ladies and gentlemen
Chris D'Elia
and everyone you know when they're done
cheering or whatever like I know I know
I'm gonna be guys guys guys he died guys
he died I'm gonna have to say that a
[ __ ] little [ __ ] load yeah and I'm
gonna be up there with my iced americano
sipping and so disrespectful but I know
but it's I know but funerals are early
so so uh so I wanna be like guys he
lived life and he you changed the world
in the little ways that people do
sometimes and also now sadly I'm gonna
let out a big [ __ ] rip fart I'm gonna
let out a [ __ ] huge just [ __ ] oh
it's gonna come out like that and I'm
gonna go like this oh [ __ ] I'm sorry and
then I'm gonna take my sunglasses off
and I'm gonna go with my mouth and I'm
gonna [ __ ] have two big middle
fingers I'm not gonna do it like they do
like that I like it I'm gonna [ __ ] it
and the whole thing's and I'm gonna go
like this my new special comes out
whenever and whatever time you're using
an item launching pad and you're gonna
disrespect me by yeah one thing what
sunglasses off in the middle of it
though that's so bad can I ask you so ok
on that note next real question so
you're almost you're gonna be 40 I'm not
even close to 40 no you're you're gonna
be 40 in 39 months right 39 and it's
gonna be nine months right so so so
really in like 14 months or something or
15 whatever it is you're gonna be 40 now
so your auto year is 12 months so your
audience and you're getting great so
your audience that's young he's going to
Maui's no let's going to shrink my
audience goes from [ __ ] they did the
[ __ ] demographic thing I went to the
demographic yeah pleasure they're 18
they were like your audience is
literally to nine ninety-two 72 they go
like this and I and I go like what
that's how big are these but what's that
demo and they go like this they're
looking at these spreadsheets and
they're all [ __ ] it's like it's like
go like this so they're like well I'm
looking here but it's just it's everyone
they go no they go it's everyone and I
go I saw for [ __ ] sake and I took my
sunglasses off and I [ __ ] walk out of
there dude well who was it that said
you've seen guys in lab coats and [ __ ]
and like yeah [ __ ] so it was a lab I
guess yeah scientists yeah looked at all
the numbers 100% never like we don't
they go like this you know these reports
we've never seen something like this you
know cuz they're [ __ ] dorks you know
so they're like they're just tossing
over [ __ ] paid you after paid they
have this yeah look I've never seen
anything like this usually demos they're
like 15 years or so and they go the
earth is just and one guy goes like this
and he's shaking and he's [ __ ]
shaking and he says mr. mr. D'Elia your
demo it's and I said what say it and he
said it's just it's 9:00 to 72 and then
did you go hissed any [ __ ] white you
go alright I go like this well I guess
that's how it's gonna be and I [ __ ]
kept my sunglasses on and I strut it out
of there and on the way out as the door
closed I [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants and I
didn't give a [ __ ] it went sad my car
all the way home and you heard this
somebody got a bucket yep and I drove
all the way home with the [ __ ] in my
pants because I don't give a [ __ ] dude
you just sat in your shop yep
okay let me ask you this so I appreciate
all that no problem so we know that now
you're gonna be 40 which means you're
gonna be an adult almost because you're
not an adult you're a tall boy you're
you say I'm right I'm not let's start
with a general question so I can help
you what do what do you think you're
[ __ ] doing
bro no I wanted to start with that
general question like stop doing that
because it's my statures in front of me
right ake your sunglasses we can both
agree that the futures not behind us
right can we agree that the futures not
behind we can agree with that okay okay
now our eyes are we're in front of us or
behind us what our eyes are where our
eyes are we're on our face in front of
us and the face is in the front right
yes so if our future now we agreed is in
front of us yeah right okay and our
faces
face forward right okay you're now my
dance teacher now my future can what is
it dude
it's too bright so I have to put these
[ __ ] shades on otherwise otherwise
otherwise otherwise otherwise oh my god
I'd say otherwise interacts now you're
familiar with cataracts because for sure
had cataract surgery did not as you're
52 no no and it's all good no but that's
how it is my guest on my podcast dude
it's so respectful how I'm being to be
brutally honest with you no it's not yes
it is so so listen bro you can't just a
general [ __ ] like my future's too bright
how is it to breath where do you where
do you think where the [ __ ] do you think
there is for you to go no my tombstones
gonna send that teenage look you know
what my tombstones gonna say what you
[ __ ] skater from the 90s he is gonna
say he just keeps kicking man and even
still it's not gonna say he kept kicking
he's gonna say he just but you're dusty
I'm not dusty dude to be honest be my
age cord ah dude what's up with coffee
you know whatever you but I don't do
that i talk about raccoons you know what
do you do Brian
what did you talk about on stage I was
artistic last night I was metaphor
really yeah what did you talk about my
act was a bit bird heavy out it was a
bit bird heavy you talked a lot about
birds cuz I'm a bird satirist um you're
not
I'm an avian humorist at least give me
that okay I will give you that you're in
avian
yeah humorous yeah yeah the point is I
can make anything funny including birds
right we'd agree with that
oh I think you're hilarious and yeah
yeah I think we're really fun yeah and
the people the people would agree yeah
that in many ways you could make the
argument without being a dick okay when
I'm not saying this okay we can say
everyone it comes to comedy stand-up
comedy okay
no big deal okay and I'm being very
strict my parameters okay that I'm the
best right dude well clearing to I don't
know if that's fair no there's game
other people out there that are pretty
damn good I mean as far as like gogo
goes right as far as what what is well
as far as to borrow one of your terms
like if you had to come up with a and I
think you've said this before
mm-hmm maybe on interviews if you had to
come up with a sound effect for what I
do the prouds okay that's copyrighted
that's copyright stuff it is covering
because because it sucks and you know
why it sucks why dude it's [ __ ] so
annoying dude let me put on my
sunglasses
look dude all right I [ __ ] saw him on
the phone when my agents were talking
about deals obviously I got stuff coming
in we got the [ __ ] guys in the lab
coats are like never seen anything like
this we've got deal after deal and they
go like that and they're like and they
come up to me and he's like um somebody
get a bucket yeah and he's like we have
another deal for you mr. D'Elia and he
pissed
he pissed again his pants are yellow at
this point right from all the pissing
he's doing because he's nervous and he's
my fan yeah so so he goes like this this
is I'm talking about all this [ __ ] am i
in and you go like this
Chris I say yeah and and I'm on I'm on a
conference call at this point right and
my I hear click click and I say guys and
one agent left
he says Chris I said what I said what
would all this clicks and he said the
rest of the agents they are they hung up
and I said what for
and they said they don't want to be on
the phone for this part and I said why
what's going on you know you're making
me nervous you're making me anxious yeah
it was like this I'm anxious hearing
this
I've tried to stop this and I said stop
what dude just lay it to me straight man
what's going on
am I getting cancelled and he says no I
said well what is it man
and he said they're making a documentary
about your shoulder
I just trouble believing that they would
do this why would the [ __ ] would they do
that and they go like that they say
because they're just getting out of
control nothing like this my aging says
no they're just they're just getting to
get out of control
and I said what and he said they said
what's the endgame here Chris do you
want them to be higher than your head I
said I don't know you know I just keep
doing the circuit training in the
[ __ ] body building and they said they
say well we can't stop the documentary
and the guys are coming and then I said
really calmly I said that's it call okay
and a handful yeah yeah and you go and I
hear click and I said what the [ __ ] did
the last eight hang up no no no that you
hung up oh and I saw now I'm alone yeah
like a lone on this [ __ ] conference
call and then I hear Chris and I say
yeah and he says I was here all along
and it's my other agent I was like you
didn't hang up he's like no I got back
on because I knew the other agent didn't
want to tell you this yeah so I got back
on and I gotta tell you and I said what
is it called and he goes like this long
sigh he goes
boom that's that's that um the last
click was me yeah the last click was me
I wasn't happy I know yeah so I'm
looking forward to your documentary I'm
not Bob boom
I'm not dude yeah I had to [ __ ] run
from my car to here because of the
[ __ ] cameras well I'm not even using
they're using that old 90s cameras that
are I know because they want to be
obnoxious and in my face about it
I am and I appreciate that and I look
forward to it I don't need another thing
that I hope they advertise on Netflix I
have a documentary being made about me
now dude I know what do you mean you
know I know why well it's so shocking
but I've been in the game all right do
you know I mean on a high level this guy
this junkyard dog has got ribs yeah I
don't appreciate you calling yourself a
I'm built bear down okay you know that
okay sure and so they followed me around
whoo okay all right so sure that's a
little bit secret right so you care that
a guy who's the director has done some
movie all right okay I'm doing all the
move all right you wouldn't know a lot
of movies okay sure and these are making
a documentary but both of us right it is
my so so they followed me around for a
month and they saw what I did yeah and
and they have a title for my dog no it's
so shocking because it's so crazy and
I'm like that's so flattering and I
agree with the title all right I agree
with the title cuz it captures my
essence okay but and I was like how are
they gonna capture my essence sure okay
who know what is alright but you brought
it up okay so what is it so the
documentary about Bryan Callen is your
Hall oh no no I know I know because I am
body I am gonna call just
we could I embody the spirit hold on so
how is this it's spelled just kung fu
kung fu' yeah you're saying oh well
that's how it's said so as I'm from I
studied in China for so long but and my
Master's okay so they're making a
documentary about you when you train as
long as I have you switch rain as some
years to train in kung foo and well
don't and you get to a point where you
actually become oh don't know dude no I
don't become a saint know it but but
what embarrassing is the way you're
saying agree with you though but just
say kung foo I'm not the one who told
Steven Spielberg to call it hold on you
see I'm trying to edit that so you're
saying you're Burkhart that you're
saying that you're saying that Steven
Spielberg is that he's making a
documentary about you I can't say his
name but okay so whoever you said is
making a documentary about you yeah and
they're calling it gongfu know what
going for boom phu comfo come full
almost I mean I'm not getting it come
foo come full okay so you're I mean I'm
doing it the way you're doing there's a
little bit of you as silent you but
you've got you've got to pronounce to
you right again going fool fool so you
see what I did say what thankful so you
may go up at the end so if I were to say
let's go and train come for right Google
there you go okay let's say I have to
give it the respect right okay but what
but okay so you're a comedian yeah
who can fail you with what with an open
hand alright so and that's yeah and
they're making a documentary which I
would never you okay sure because you
have it all right okay so I bility you
how they give up a so so in the other
martial artist you know that I that I
studied for [ __ ] ever don't say cut
out they oh no no
a Japanese accent right I mean and
that's that I don't like that right mmm
no and I and this and I know you train
right but you know I've trained I am
sick I am training all right
you've trained and maybe you train still
all right I'll give that I'll give that
much you know I for six years did you
geez you know that I've done for six
years I've done juji's it's like oh you
jeez you jeez I've done you jeans great
darling you have to say geez I know I'm
saying but you're saying gee no no I for
six years I know but it's obnoxious to
it you have not trained long enough to
actually call it JIT Serge is G's
jiu-jitsu JIT so I just said jits ah
that's not yeah all right so anyway
we've have to lock you up right
why go [ __ ] you all right like you don't
like it does it count as [ __ ] someone
up if there's no shots or anything but
but but the the guy goes the guy who
loses goes no dude you you know that I
could stop your heart dude right no I
love by the way you're almost 49 52 and
this is Howard this is this is so that
there's [ __ ] Pete guys who do business
and let crunch numbers and [ __ ] and this
is our job yeah and there's doctors
there's doctors yeah but this is our job
well I see that like I stopped what I
did my last corporate gig some I don't
think I can do them anymore because they
the rules and the the protocol that you
have to observe like and when you work
for Google you were there is a there is
a puritanical yeah I haven't work for
Google so I don't want to say this
bigger but a lot of offices it seems
there's this puritanical way of speaking
and yeah behaving I just couldn't I
wouldn't even know at this point it's
probably gotten so out of hand you know
like you I the only thing I know is form
it's from [ __ ] school when I was in
school yeah I'm sure it's gotten way
worse and whereas I was in school hug
anymore like I so I think my network or
any and you're not ready to have so you
like to you creepy place no I just like
to hug without pants but you you can't
like there are certain things like humor
really careful yeah we'd get I'd be
fired to me yeah I know and it's it's
it's weird too because it's like it's
definitely like a problem with like
fringe groups like because here's the
deal that's when I when I do I did a
show get in Connecticut a college show
and it yeah when uh a month ago okay and
I and the show was great I they warned
you about anything or no I
although I won't do the show and so I
did the show it was great
applause breaks everyone's happy this
and that and then one person writes a
blog about the show and and they said I
was funny it wasn't like bashing me but
they were like this one part was just to
this and that and it was offensive and
it's just like well that because that's
called virtue signal right also this is
a culture where if you can find anything
racist or anything homophobic it right
here I'm like yeah you you're a hero you
get brownie pure so so it doesn't matter
what you're intentionally matter you're
not a racist traitor but if they can
just find something any it was like she
had to find something yeah that was that
was wrong with it yeah and it is a
fringe it is a fringe group because my
point and that's how you prove it is
that the show was great everyone was
laughing everyone was giving me applause
breaks and then the one person writes
two things yes and then anyone who
hasn't been to the show they read that
that's right so it's like that's right
but I do think that people are aware
like at the end of the day you're still
selling out yeah yeah I can't go to
Chris Lea because this blog but it is
unfortunate because one blog can cause
you do have to answer to it sometimes
sometimes yeah and I just think it sucks
and I think that the press is so
irresponsible because I'll pick up on
that little yeah it's a weird aren't
even true and you know a lot of this
stuff is I don't even know who's writing
it I'm not I don't even trust that it's
a human being sometimes it's like it's
BOTS yeah yeah it's it's a weird thing
because it's not it's definitely not um
it's definitely not the majority yeah
like well you know Sam Harris on his
podcast had this woman who worked for
Homeland Security or something and she
was a computer engineer and she started
finding that there were people she found
that they were staging rallies appro
Texas rally and then a pro Islam rally
or a pro you know immigration rally and
a pro you
No whatever and they were being staged
across the street from each other and
she was like who's doing this and she
found out it was Russia
it was literally Russian it dude it's
incredible I will head around the
podcast Russia is very instrumental in
they have a propaganda machine sure in
trying to so social discord in this
country it's [ __ ] crazy so a lot of
times you have to be really suspicious
of a that's [ __ ] weird their vaccine
videos on YouTube made by Russian quote
quote unquote Patriots as Putin calls
but so just to make us seem confused
yeah yeah and it does cause some issues
I suppose yeah it's so weird like if it
like if I if if I was in Russia and
somebody and I was in the government and
somebody was like we got to do this we
got to make American confused by making
YouTube videos about vente about
vaccinations or antibac said I would be
like what will let's spend our time
doing other stuff you know what I mean
and I wouldn't even think I simply I
would be like this isn't gonna work
right does work yeah which is why I'm
not in the Russian government right a
lot of them are kind of loosely paid by
the government you know it's weird
weird it's a very strange it's a yeah
have you you've not have you ever been
outside the United States of America
yeah dude are you kidding me are you god
are you kidding me
where have you gone do you know that
[ __ ] song that goes no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no I
could just be like my
into London France praying over there
right now and just keep listing cities
do it remember a membership into
Zimbabwe Sweden France Britain baboon by
the way I said to crunches I said the
same place already
I've been to Australia I've been to have
you been in Canada I've been yeah well
Toriko I've been to [ __ ] London cool
I've been to London I've been to eat I
is how I say I be that the stuff scandal
drama mm-hmm I've been a Rome yeah
did you know anything mm-hmm oh yeah
when you saw old buildings do you have
any idea yeah mm-hmm what Rome's about
oh yeah yeah big time you go to the
Sistine Chapel I want to present you
know painted the Sistine Chapel yeah Oh
John Grisham know if that's an author
what no dude mechanic okay I know it's
bigger than usual oh my god I know it's
my nose into one of the ninja turtles no
that's not what I have to get you more
educated no I know one of the ninja I
knew one of the ninja turtles did the
[ __ ] cystines
I want to know about have you had
celebrities 100% who's the most famous
celebrity you've had reach out to you
Christ okay like I don't know that's
Christ true Christ what did he say he
goes like this thank you for taking what
I've given you and putting it you know
exponentially into the world he goes
like this mine even I even the all-seer
even I didn't have any idea that you
could take it this far he goes like that
so he was singing the way they do like
the yeah I guess I don't know and it was
like when I originally put you on this
earth I didn't think that you would
exceed my expectations but you did
it goes like that it's like what that's
incredible yeah maybe bestow anything
any rewards so yeah he gave me these
because he was like here are some
glasses because you're going since your
faces in the front of you and the past
is behind you and the future is way far
ahead it's gonna get shiny and bright
and you need these sunglasses to shield
your vision so he gave me these
sunglasses that's a main I know he's
[ __ ] weird if you know did he say
anything about the fact that I'll be in
Orlando he said one day Saturday's two
tickets are going Super Saturday
practically made Rafi what he said was
if you're a fan of Christmas Chris
D'Elia definitely go outside of the
Orlando Improv and picket that Brian
counts going to be there that's what
they said right said yeah Christ say
it's living howlin is my face no no it's
like this if you need supplies I've got
markers and white board how does he make
but so far he oh no he go he said he
said don't have a very nice voice Thanks
I don't know why you don't sing oh you
do what what yeah well I don't you're on
M&Ms oh you know I did have the number
one song in the world for a while right
give you money 9 take it you didn't take
it nope Wow no dance what what what you
know I think I'm saying he said no and
you don't father's the [ __ ] out of me
I'll be honest yes right chefs rises I
have no surprise anymore I'm sorry my
rice is free
ok I thought I thought you're going down
a different Lane no I wasn't dope finger
pistol me um what the [ __ ] was I saying
haha you know what pisses me off yeah
what
now I forgot some of all my fans doing
something to you oh yeah yeah I know
see I know you know I get sweet tart
tart Nashville and then they wear dance
shirts that your shows yeah yeah I'm the
president I'm prom knee president press
[ __ ] it up I'm on the prom knee pres
I'm the omnipresent oh and when Phil
Lamarr with Artie Lange we were on um we
were on MADtv any cuz it's just
omnipresent or something omnipresent
Langa's what what's that mean again it
just means you're in I know what the
[ __ ] it means well don't add TV but
don't use words right cuz it's annoying
when you use big words like omnipresent
is like the right that's the limit yeah
you start using bigger words I think the
otherwise the conversation becomes
scatological and we've no way hold it
okay see I mean no see we want it we
want to keep things fastidious and no
dude don't say that's right but we want
to cry right right I understand I
understand what you're doing yeah so
what I want to talk about what do we
think of paper straws dude well what do
we think I think that Brian turtles
right and that is wrong no it is they
don't save and let me be real clear yeah
they don't save two turtles they maybe
did one video where a turtle cook a
straw out of its [ __ ] nostrils yeah
yeah yeah but they don't save another
turtle they don't but so what do we do
about all the plastics in the ocean you
follow environmental a hundred percent
of a very environmental yes so what
would you do environmental eyes what
would you do about all the plastic well
what we would what doesn't help but you
know you know by the way do you know how
much percentage plastic you know how
much percentage the the [ __ ] straws
are all the straws yeah for plastic yeah
miniscule really yeah miniscule and the
they're not all paper right only some of
them are [ __ ] paper right therefore
and let me be very clear you're not
saving tutor
but if we can just save one but they did
okay and that was a freak thing
yeah what's happened is the fire what is
it so oh my god that's an oxen and what
you can't you can't what
say something and then snapped well it's
a book for emphasis it's for emphasis
but that's not that's so I say something
yeah
so I say something like [ __ ] this end
table now I have fire fire tattooed all
right do you have lighting I don't know
any because besides spending money on
yeah coffee that's not you have any
charities that'll any charities that you
give answer quickly give me the net 100%
answer quick benefits so for cancer kids
and double-a-c-p
all sorts of [ __ ] and wcp give me you
give the National Advancement of Colored
People mmm are you lying to me I would
never lie to you so how much do you give
to the N double AC P seven I can let you
do I can tell you're thinking right in
heaven $700 no I'm not saying then it's
not a thousand dollars and I am big on
GoFundMe
and I I think you're lying our profiles
on GoFundMe I want you to give to
charity from now on I do give to charity
no you don't yes I do exactly I support
charity I've you drive ridiculous cars
bro sell one of your impossibly
expensive cars no have a mustard yellow
well which is so it's desert right it's
not desert I've seen it's deserts we all
mustard we should call it weak mustard
its mustard with sand in it it's sandy
mustard it's Desert Storm we call India
desert I don't call it that the two of
us do it's sandy mustard okay
cheap Mercedes expensive as well well
you don't need it I don't need it
so what get rid of it but I give it to
another a
I can't have a friend who wears that
chain and zips around I know I went a
chain I'm from New Jersey you know no
you're not I'm from the your Pasadena
mama's boy I'm not a passive my mom oh I
love my mom you're not gonna take that
from me you're not gonna [ __ ] turn
that on its head
I love my mom mama Papa's boy no no but
I'll tell you what
what from New Jersey bro I'm from New
Jersey I moved out here when I was 12
years old that's her fake accent no it's
not bro this is the real me but I cover
it for Hollywood he's [ __ ] cooks in
Hollywood they want to hear me be like
hey what's up what's going on but bro
I'm from New Jersey
yeah and I'm from [ __ ] Montclair New
Jersey dude no you're not I've had
friends I have friends they look at you
look at him [ __ ] two times yeah
they'll bury you you look at them
[ __ ] twice Hey look at my friends
twice look at my friends twice they'll
bury ya
don't know what was that that sound like
gasps excuse me mmm I hate you well yeah
that's because you're a [ __ ]
communist and this is very a mil I'm not
you're not I'm an American I don't even
do that yeah yeah you don't think
outside the don'ts take a [ __ ] nap my
podcast dude so what's next for Chris
D'Elia are you gonna do any movies
didn't you do them you know what yeah
what what happened that it's coming out
later on this like that where is it it's
coming on that later on this year you
think I lied about that do you get I do
think that acting is gonna take a half
[ __ ] backseat cuz podcasting a stand
better well it's just I want to do but I
want to act in stuff that I can just
that is like the interesting to me
otherwise I'll just do stand-up in
podcast you get offered like a part I
can just see her agent Gaad it's for a
lawyer
oh yeah well yeah something like they
were like hey yeah it's a cool thing and
you play this lawyer on TV and I was
like um and you would have jumped at it
back in the day and yeah yeah yeah but
they were like loads read it and I was
like I read it and I was like ya know
cuz if I had to do this for eight years
oh my god dah you'd end up seeing a lot
of the stuff inside of my body on the
outside of my that's right eventually
because I would [ __ ] make kill myself
yeah yeah when you're doing a one hour I
wish people could see what that is it's
just too much I mean dude I you know I'm
on that show you coming up you know
which is a [ __ ] big hit and I really
wanted to do it because I really liked
the show
like I saw the first season you know
what you you yeah and and it's great
it's a [ __ ] good show and they were
like hey you know like I'm on them in a
few I'm in a few episodes within the new
season then and it's it's I just
realized a lot of the time first of all
it's a drama you know and so you're
saying you're having fun on set is not
necessarily yeah the right word right
it's because because unless you have
playmates yeah right but and I'm a guest
so I don't know the guys they already
know all each other and [ __ ] and it was
it was an experience that I liked doing
it I'm glad that I did it but funds the
wrong word right if you're not doing a
comedy it's not fun you know like think
about Leonardo DiCaprio in the revenant
he's doing his dream job he's doing
exactly what he wants to do but never oh
my god but that's not fun oh I mean I
went shooting that in Patagonia or
wherever it's not fun and being like
yeah like I was like I would I'd rather
do anything else for real yeah like its
suck you're doing it because you know
it's challenging and you and you're an
artist and all that [ __ ] that's all the
argument for enhance it that's great I
don't care yeah I know I know lesson
endurance I care a little bit like I
would like to do some [ __ ] like that
because it's like out of my comfort zone
and it's and you know I would like to
act in in [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] but I was
like the Game of Thrones they did 11
weeks of night shoots yeah 11 it's
really depressing and it's really boring
oh yeah literally it was crazy
it's definitely freezing you see their
breath ah but you're in the background
mostly you're standing I know
oh and here's the other thing too you
don't realize that when you're acting
you so like even if you're in a movie
where you're one of the leads and one of
the leads right yeah
even put it take take it take the movie
taken yeah
Liam Neeson yeah maybe two of those
scenes yeah he was like alright let's go
I'm gonna sink my teeth in that's right
that whole [ __ ] I will find you and I
will kill you yeah now he had to do that
scene 20 times right 20 times in a row
by the fifth time you're like okay okay
I did it I gotta keep doing it okay
now there's one or two of those scenes a
movie yeah
otherwise you're this is the scene you
walk in you put your keys down you turn
on the TV I know and you got to do that
seven you do that 17 times now you're
gay now you're Liam Neeson you're making
millions of dollars they give you knock
did they offer you if you audition for
the part of the sex trafficker and that
no I you had dammit dude I know I'm not
in taken do you're not in no you played
all the sex guys no I didn't do it
you're saying extra I know what you're
saying you're saying I look like a perv
and I [ __ ] I'm like I don't I I don't
play any good look say that good luck no
the way you said in the movie I didn't
say it in the movie they did use my
voice for the audio but that's but not I
was in the night it's luck good luck no
but you're right you're right about how
[ __ ] like it's tedious hideous I said
the word first and then you ripped it
for me but I said the words I told you
what it was what it meant but you don't
need like it like the the minutiae the
details of having to smolder on screen
walk into a room I remember watching
James Caan I did an episode of and you
guys were young James Caan was in The
Godfather Hall of Fame actor he was in
Las Vegas he it was like we shot till
3:00 in the morning he was walking
across the parking lot and they had this
swooshing camera and he would just walk
really fast and point and he kept doing
that over over yeah huh you were in the
show Las Vegas Lee I did an episode um
what happened but right well that was
when I'd see those hours and I was like
I did CSI and I was like that's I can't
do this yeah I can't be here for 16
hours I don't want to do I want to thank
God for stand up in parkas I mean I but
we we're a little different because I I
would like here's the thing I love
seeing that end product like I like
that's why you know probably a lot of
you do it like dude I would jump at the
chance to do a [ __ ] thing like take
and I don't give a [ __ ]
even if anybody's gonna see it I just
want to [ __ ] see if you can like yeah
see if I could do it you don't I mean
like that to me that's that it's not
easy no I mean a good actor like that is
not easy that's it's a thing you have to
have a [ __ ] some sort of star quality
and you know but it's not everybody can
do it but but I want to do that [ __ ] and
but but my point is here's the thing
it's like I'm gonna if I'm do if I'm
gonna take a break from doing stand-up
yeah if I'm gonna take a break from
doing you know the podcasts
congratulations but ya know you already
listened to this week's because now you
listen to this one you do the second but
alright you you know if I'm gonna take a
break from doing it it's got to be
something that's gonna put me out of my
comfort zone challenge me right you know
in an interesting way hmm something
scares you a little bit yeah a little
yeah you have not no you're and do it
yeah like like like a playing a pro
wrestler like what the [ __ ] I would
never do that if someone's like yeah
they thought they'd be interested
playing a pro right be like oh that's
kind of interesting let me read the
[ __ ] thing maybe I was a [ __ ] for it
or whatever is something you just would
never yes so they haven't really think
of myself to our being in the Bryan
Callen biopic you know biopic but yeah
don't say biopic right because that's
[ __ ] annoying as [ __ ] but you know
what I mean right that's awesome if they
made a biopic of you who would play you
I mean you'd have to have somebody
Moranis right what did you say
no I'm asking you if you saw Honey I
Shrunk the Kids you've seen that right
Moran you think Rick Moranis would play
me well I brought him up at his age now
right he's retired now not that that is
young right this one there you go I mean
well your little yeah you got it there
couple things your little rounder in the
face gotta take him back now if he was
gonna do your biopic take it back no
idea I don't want it you know what a
[ __ ] spindly legs do we forget how
spindly my legs are did you forget
dude okay can't give I'm right just out
of reach right Wow Rick Moranis would
play you just on your biopic see that's
how you get out of a fight you exhaust
the guy I'm spindle II hood like didn't
work so yes so that's who would play you
in it's fine I think it's good yeah
thanks man no problem let's do some
current events I'm already bored well
it's been 45 minutes has it don't don't
do that
all right is that is that a sound effect
for my shows you go tomorrow I go in
tomorrow to Orlando Orlando improv you
guys get your ticket well if you're my
fan I final mountain fan of mine oh you
looks more like Kalin there in the
bottom no no it'll off in the middle
getting depressed go go a little to the
right
all right into right the second one of
the line I feel like he's my brother
who'd there you go we didn't do the
sports who goes my brother was the
athlete that's what he said my brother
was the athlete so uh yeah no Orlando
and if you're fan of mine go to fly to
Edmonton instead and fly to Victoria BC
instead none of that's where I'm going
you get tickets where are you gonna be
Edmonton I like it Mindy yeah it's a
[ __ ] great commentator it's it is a
great comedy town its own oil town yeah
Edmonton Oilers there's a lot of drugs
there and you didn't wake Kane right
can't wait yeah do a lot of blow gonna
Edmonton was where I saw below where I
saw a brick of cocaine and a man with a
neck the size of a fire hydrant shaving
off the brick with a razor blade
yes shaving off a break and he looked at
me he goes Eddie call me by that oh yeah
yeah hanging over there yeah Eddie come
do some and that straw so I was like oh
no it's okay I go I'm in a rental car I
got intimidated cuz they were gangsters
yeah I go no I'm in a rental car
that's what I said well that doesn't
make any sense our stuff it's really
good
he was from Serbia I'm in a rental car
that's how scared you were
Thank You Serbia tanks you know rest
friends are serving gas also why were
you bigger than me with him I was
invited to a house party and the manager
this is why I don't go today these guys
are fun and I had nothing to do so I was
like alright here comes with venture and
I followed them in their white Mercedes
I then found out because I ran into one
of their friends that they all went to
jail for like ten years God for running
a major situation well man look at that
look at how good-looking I was that's
what they look like but much bigger you
look good huh you're a good actor
hmm you're a good actor yeah yeah I mean
I've been doing it for 25 years so don't
say just say good right so I'm there's a
chance I could be great right if I open
up if I really want it no but they say
go they go like you they go in casting
rooms they'll be like we get Bryan
Callen and then you know after
everyone's like who's that they go like
now listen amigo like no he was like the
Iranian that's because I get so lost in
the character you don't know me from one
role to the next and here's the other
thing you know that I can dig deep right
I can dig deep and there I am is the
Joker no Ryan you're you're not you
don't play the Joker Joker Moog that's
what is okay that's lying right so that
picture is lying right that would just
be a clickbait picture yeah or or I'm
playing the Joker no it says Bryan
Callen cast in Joker right there on the
side everyone they as in okay I don't
know okay right well you know cuz you
did it right yeah at any point in
shooting did you go
alright never mind dude you know you lie
so never mind yeah I've done a lot of
big movies dude there you go there I am
no that's not you that's Joaquin Phoenix
how do you know that oh so I guess is of
his face I guess that picture is a lot
is lying right yeah cuz it's from we
have a very some Hanning animated
times.com and so argue with them right
right ok argue with them I'm not his
cousin Kurt all right here we go so this
went viral on the latest episode of
Arthur there we go as I say hey Arnold
but on the latest episode of Arthur it
came out that a beloved teacher is
actually getting married to a man hmm
oh another cartoon yeah on a cartoon
well you know what we have this idea
that we have to protect our kids from
these kinds of things that's a reality
and the truth and then and I approve
sure all right but that literally if
they want to make a cartoon character
gay I actually couldn't even care less
well I know ahead oh that's a reality
they probably have teachers that are gay
and the teachers might want to get
married yeah you know I don't think the
state should be involved and anybody
should be involved in telling two people
who love each other that they can't get
married
because I think but you know this is a
new thing in our history this is a new
thing that all of us they won the
argument and they earned that argument
gay people and activists who did a lot
to get here and we've accepted it and
and that's a big deal man that's that
was why didn't have anything to do with
it they did that's a hard thing to
[ __ ] win man but all of us are all
like you know [ __ ] it yeah ro I can't
argue that it's bad right I can't argue
there are people who would say well it's
a bad message to send a kids or
something because it's you know it saves
against family values and traditional
marriage and work though there's all
that stuff but that you that was up
until 10 minutes ago
then there's still a lot of people feel
that way but in my opinion the true
we have gay people in the world and
they're born that way and they love the
same sex and if you want to be in the
business of justifying why they can't
get married
good luck I can't come up with one
legitimate ethical or moral philosophy
to back that up
so it's a little disrespectful that they
chose the guy who named rat turned to be
gay but okay well listen man hey give
them Ratburn no that's come on you're
being super progressive they're like
they're like you know what dude hey how
about this yeah well it'd be like we
can't fight it anymore you know we got
to make one of them gay and then some
guy in the back goes some really [ __ ]
hetero just it was a good give them
Ratburn you know we'll just like give
them like how about how about Arthur how
about make Arthur gay and then I'm happy
well I'm aggressive though I do I like
that osmosis jones goes mr. Ratburn from
Arthur is gay did you know do you know
how amazing it is that someone who's
been on the show from the start someone
who's on main character is openly gay
and got married on a kids show PBS KIDS
really is that [ __ ] plus all the
students are at his wedding here I love
that you really are that [ __ ] that's an
aggressive compliment yeah hey it's
great that mr. Ratburn marries a
boyfriend but we still don't know how
Arthur's classes are staying on his head
it's 2019 we need answers yeah that
person is right they do need to do it
step by step and I want to explain the
class let's move on there you go so a
student run humor publication got in
trouble for photoshopping a photo of
Anne Frank's face onto another woman's
body with the the premise of what they
wrote was that Anne Frank should've had
died because she would have been hot if
she survived
wait Oh God so do you know Anne Frank do
you know anything about Anne Frank Chris
D'Elia
yeah tell me about it so she loved you
have to know about Anne Frank what is
the book she wrote yeah like How to Lose
a Guy in 10 days
no no it's the Diary of Anne Frank right
yeah and she was in the Attic they lived
in an attic no because she was hiding
and what hiding from the [ __ ] Nazis
yes her and I know so much [ __ ] dude and
I believe it was in Holland wasn't it
shut up can we look that out today
[ __ ] matter this guy well it's
important I love him and she was sent
off to Auschwitz her the only person who
survived was her father yeah the whole
family and she wrote before she died I
still believe in my heart that she that
people are good and in their essence
regardless and her father says she
shames me with her humanity she was an
amazing woman man mmm child I'm sorry
yeah fourteen-year-old girl yeah wow
that's a powerful book yeah and maybe
she would have been hot okay but that's
not the point here and Asian trapped in
Amsterdam by the German occupation oh
wait what did they do though they were
Jews no no no I know that she wasn't the
Nazis didn't like I know I'm asking what
the National Lampoon did or what was it
they just made this um edit with Anne
Frank's face on it and saying that she
would have been hot so it was a little
joke and a lot of people were really
angry about it certain things in your
comedy rush but it's comic comedy is and
that is a hilarious you have to go you
have to go you have to push the envelope
in comedy otherwise you're not gonna
know where it is and it's constantly
changing so you have to do it but that's
that's odd nobody kind of stopped that
one well at the before I got public yeah
it's it is a funny picture and I think
that yeah but it's so easy yeah it's
like I guess I guess people are like
this is offensive because of what she
did it's not really offensive because of
that oops right you're interrupting me
so oops but it's just like just try a
little harder I agree but I mean at the
same time so you're allowed to no no no
and then you're also allowed to protest
it right so here both sides are on the
out I agree they're definitely allowed
to do that you're just you're gonna you
got to know if you do that you're gonna
get some heat get that as a tattoo I
think there'll be a really bad idea do
it I'll do it over my whole back live on
the edge
right member up them yet all the Ottoman
podcast where you're the guest alive
gasps hey how you don't have guests on
congratulate nope you know what I'll
come oh come on you can ask me questions
hey it's me
so uber has finally finally the option
wait quiet mode for drivers to prevent
conversations - just who the [ __ ] - shut
the [ __ ] up over drop over drivers like
who dude that's amazing so you don't get
a set so you can say I want a quiet dude
yes don't sell on the app you can put in
your preference only if you order an
uber black or a burr black SUV that you
would want a quite a quiet ride you
don't want to speak to the driver you
may want to do some work just don't feel
like talking it's nice so they have that
feature now but it's only for their
blacker rights people no no I don't hate
people but you're you'd be good used to
this because when you're you often in a
room with quiet people like your shows
that the Orlando Improv yeah and another
said quiet that's right but I think that
what I'm saying do you do you have do
you have an option because what I was
did to get this from you do you have an
option on your shows to go to the quiet
shows because when I go and I look at
you doing stand-up now it's not very
loud right now you're talking but other
people are kind of more it's like it's a
TED talk I want to snow or no kind of a
library there are there are moments in
my show right where okay so have you
ever heard of have you ever heard of the
factor have you heard of that so dude
and that's when you're all you go okay
so there's a moment where there's a
respite okay I mean no--don't it was
like that when the storm rings you're
okay
in the storm right in the tempest yeah
no I'll give you a harbor sometimes I
hate you as some [ __ ] where you just go
they've never even heard that right
right is that it's called there's a
certain what bride joke is I think that
no I chose not a British I think that
there's I've had a lot of
critics who really know the difference
say there is a majesty to his
performance I'm gonna Google those words
in quotes and Bryan Callen and nothing
will come up is a majesty but cell
Majesty but the thing is but the thing
is when most of your comedy show would
have that quote unquote off actor right
where's the laughs right so when I walk
into a room what's up what's up now
what's that little boy what was that
little boy no quiet you quiet
you owe me be quiet wide cuz I should be
in your audience that one was extra that
was a hard slam
welcome to Denny's what's not you owe me
to 298 that was an all-american slam no
I'm not giving you tonight can I get you
anything else
no ah keep going alright this one Empire
is gonna end next season and then they
don't have any plans to bring Jesse Beck
well no because that's how surprising at
all cuz he's a lying about you know he
still hasn't come out and said I'm a
piece of [ __ ] yeah Terry I like how
excited we were in the day the day and
age where you could just ride out your
[ __ ] lie till the end you know what I
mean
although that people will just believe
but yeah but people some people believe
them dude well they just they don't
believe them they just choose to write
history yeah but I mean like after that
one girl at the [ __ ] Emmys or
whatever she's like I'm sorry Stan with
Jesse smell like yeah what are you doing
dum-dum what are you doing again nobody
for real in real life actually [ __ ]
thinks that or is on her side she that
girl's a dum-dum well I don't even know
who did that but that girl's a [ __ ]
dum-dum and also um this guy's a [ __ ]
idiot you know bad guy he's a bad guy
Jesus oh well he's a sociopath
yes I agree I'm he's gotta be a
sociopath what off yeah what a weirdo
and a live weirdo weirdo weirdo I just
have no respect stuff people like who do
[ __ ] like there are real victims out
there that go through [ __ ] and it's
horrible and and and and minorities you
know like the black the black police
superintendent said as a black man yes
I put a noose around his neck you know
this is something that I he was so aware
of the racial history of Chicago lived
it fought his way through it I mean he
was just like this [ __ ]
and you're gonna [ __ ] just use that
you're a war profiteer ya know it's
literally like being a war prop it's the
worst kind of person I think I agree I
agree Mike I would like how constant you
see the constants blue thing that's here
- okay I go into that yeah what do you
think he'll ever make it back I mean not
in 20 years
all right good 20 years real quick on
now and - so one of the biggest things
was if he did if the police found two
white people that were that fit the
description
yeah chances are people believe Jesse
would be like yeah that even they're
innocent he'll be like yeah those are
the guys well he's a bad you would have
liked to put them in jail oh yeah yeah
which is the sociopath yeah no Chappelle
yeah yeah I would have [ __ ] put guys
who didn't give us any more bad guy all
the way our but this is the this is
another version of that Constance Wu and
not not what happened but how she put up
walls Damon so Constance will admitted
she was upset at having to return and
fresh off the boat okay
I talked about there's a lot of my
podcast and you can [ __ ] go look at
it it's not congratulations it was like
the last episode ah but anyway Wow so
upset right now that I'm literally
crying when they just [ __ ] they
announced they're gonna renew readership
thing so this [ __ ] Constance whoa so
she was on the one crazy rich Asians
right no that's so she was on the show I
guess I thought my take is she thinks
she's a movie star now and she doesn't
want to have to do [ __ ]
fresh-off-the-boat is the show right
okay so she now it got picked up and
she's all off [ __ ] I'm so subset right
now and now and and so when it they
posted it on the [ __ ] show account on
Instagram and she wrote dislike under it
and oh I'm sorry you're upset about
being on a television show I'm making
money it's hard to hear someone
complaining about it then this one [ __ ]
Oh whisper funko whisper just think
about all the actors and crew stares
shows didn't get renewed and are
devastated so maybe you shouldn't be so
upset yours got renewed but here's the
nice but here's the other thing though
you you're you what about all the people
on your crew yeah that [ __ ] are
feeding
families that are so happy and you're
just gonna come in with this [ __ ]
ungrateful attitude and what she says
after this is just the real thing that
[ __ ] got me
today's tweets and we're on the heels of
a rough day and we're ill-timed with the
new with the news of the show please
know I'm so grateful for
fresh-off-the-boat renewal
I love the cast and crew I'm proud to be
a part of it for all the fan support
thank you for all the support casual use
of the word [ __ ] thank you to she's
acting like the word like the work we
had the problem with the big word is the
word [ __ ] yes you're an ungrateful
[ __ ] you're an angry
you're a [ __ ] lucky exactly [ __ ] and
guess what and I said this on my [ __ ]
Parkinson I mean it
if this show if they just not even wrote
her out if they didn't change the actor
if they didn't even write her out if
they just stopped her character yeah if
the next episode started they never
mentioned her character again nobody
wouldn't give up nobody would nobody
would give a [ __ ] you are a lucky
[ __ ] and you know what nobody gives a
[ __ ] [ __ ] about you I so as we right
up lose a you're the what's the guy's
[ __ ] rat [ __ ] what was the guy's name
in the rap and rap no in the in the in
Arthur burn yeah you're a [ __ ] rat
burn bro you you you you suck and here's
that here's the thing dude when go to
apology go to a [ __ ] two things go to
the and Bible ask again the last
paragraph listen to this [ __ ] this is
the [ __ ] that made me do a [ __ ] cotta
in my house alone okay people can't hold
conflicting feelings in the heart so she
was all going on about how upset she was
because she can't do this project now
that is that that because she's gonna be
in production the show which I get which
is understandable and you can be upset
about that and still love your crew
which is what she's saying here in the
beginning but the end of this listen to
this people can hold conflicting
feelings inner hearts that conflict is a
part of being human so I can both love
this show cast crew but at the same time
be disappointed that I lost the other
unrelated job now okay fine yes she's
right
also ill-timed you're an [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] for saying dislike on the
Instagram page right now
appreciate those who have given me the
space and faith to believe what I say
about both parts of my heart now this is
the part that makes me want to [ __ ]
do Coty's till the Sun comes up dude
thank you it is meaningful when you make
the choice to believe women this is why
people don't believe victims not done
with the sentence you piece of [ __ ] now
I'm done you are a [ __ ] I don't never
not tell you right now dude that is the
worst person oh my god what an art or a
sociopath you know I'd have a baby with
Jesse Malloy have a baby with me just
below that baby I know and that baby
will come out and that people will come
out and the baby will not give up that
no that baby will rise out to be the
Antichrist it's parents you are what a
terrible person what up without lawful
that you're gonna use dice movement to
try and [ __ ] build women up ah this
is real victims that people were raped
Wow people were raped when you rape then
you're gonna say oh well I don't want to
be on this show but believe me for a
good reason
somebody's been doing this for 25
[ __ ] years and failed a lot and
didn't get those shows renewed over and
over and didn't get my show it's it's so
[ __ ] insulting you don't know how
lucky you are pick up a [ __ ]
newspaper or a history book or anything
you lucky overfed [ __ ] you're
terrible Constance Wu you're terrible
you're terrible she's just awful lucky
you're lucky you said yeah don't you
serve it yeah I mean I can't imagine
being a cast member or a crew going back
to that set no no I ran that show but
she's off ya know right out no nothing
no mention just throw no mention that's
how [ __ ] daliyah does it no man
you're gone and the other actors get
scenes were there crying and it's a
comedy I don't give a [ __ ] there in the
revenant now what if they're in the
revenant no I they get to use their
chops but what about Jeep but then now
she gets what she wants
couldn't you keep her in and she's just
every long even bury episode she's just
comes out she goes ah my feet it's again
I gotta go back to the bathroom a [ __ ] I
got the runs
y'all just gotta go right back into the
toilet and you just hear oh wow oh wow
she's just [ __ ] and you have her
[ __ ] with itchy feet that's good
over and over good every episo-- what
dude I want that shine that's me
I got a yeah this network TV I got to do
that or this is her part in every scene
yeah every single scene yes she works
every day yeah every single scene she
comes in no matter what the scene is no
matter how many characters she comes in
and there's a [ __ ] mid shot of her
saying would you guys like some tea
that's it every scene that's a football
scene if there's a [ __ ] scene with
one person yeah in their bedroom getting
ready yep she comes in would you like
some tea I may have a better one what I
think in one Episode everything's fine
she bumps into an old lady huh she's got
beads and she's got her and and she goes
get out of my way you old bag and the
woman falls dead she kind of pushed the
waterfall down the woman turns and gets
up and she looks at her and goes yeah
and she [ __ ] disappears and consum
was like weirdo what do you do cast a
spell and then it toward the end of that
episode she has one big thick elephant
hair growing out of the end that's
really good yeah and then by episode
three her whole face and she's got to be
a makeup for five hours for this very
whole face is covered in hair oh good
and she suffers the she can't get rid of
and it's giant elephant hairs on her
face and so she has to shave her face
and it keeps growing
yeah that's a no rate character general
so her whole [ __ ] see season is her
she's L hairy face yep
and then she I mean she dies cuz the
hair starts growing in her throat
we can write her off but her last line
is pop oh yeah and she dies from her
throat at every episode after that yeah
is every episode lashes back to her
funeral so she still needs to come back
and shoot and it's not because that's a
really good idea yeah that's an amazing
idea need you lay down lay down we get
some more hair on her face and she died
hairy and put some hair in her mouth cuz
the hairs growing out of her throat oh
great alright so there it is people like
this dude hey what a terrible person I'm
out what does she feel like that go go
go we don't meet you and you make the
choice to believe I'm nude Wow she's
just terrible yeah is she getting a lot
of backlash oh yeah
crushed whatever enjoy your 70 grand an
episode of yeah that'll and yeah yeah
and anyway moving on alright so a show
that didn't make it as the Steve Harvey
Show and then he's being replaced for
his other show that little kids show
little big what's that called little
little big shot little big shots yeah
being replaced by Melissa McCarthy after
his show got canceled they announced
that he's gonna be replaced by Melissa
McCarthy as well for the other show that
he does and then Kelly Clarkson is gonna
take the spot that his old show was at
what is his show it's TV special oh well
yeah he does like three other shows he
makes so much money oh yeah what's it
matter let me know how much I guess he
guy he likes workers that's cool I think
his wife spent something like fifty
sixty thousand dollars on chandelier for
the closet oh yeah well I'll tell you
what dude that guy crushes - yeah it's a
comic oh yeah it's funny [ __ ] yeah now
Steve Harvey's a real comic I like him I
like that I've done his show oh yeah The
Steve Harvey Show yeah and just as a
guest and it's just like a trip man they
love him he's he's great I love a comic
like that who's know who earned a comedy
yeah earned it he's a fan
real common yeah he did you see him
roast the [ __ ] football players brow
[ __ ] it was funny man really dude I
don't know if it was like an ESP I think
he just got on stage and just started
roasting these football he's the real
deal he's the real deal
it was you've been on the road for how
many think he figures out in order of 25
years before he yeah I think was that
what you do I there it is on the letter
talk show so I'm gonna left not a
participant I mean he just walking out
like a ball probably I mean look at all
who's in front of to these people are
that girls boy look Jon Hamm is there
watch this [ __ ] set let me go pause
this for a sec till they don't I've done
shows for only football players they
don't want to laugh they don't laugh
I've done it too they don't want to let
because they don't want to be the guy
who laughs the hardest this is that
person there's a quote on walls that
dork I've been there they got to be cool
people don't realize how hard this is
just this dude what what legends say
that's great when he just [ __ ] Oakley
right when he gets into the look at him
just doing it I'm challenging yeah
there's an amazing way to do it's an
amazing making it about that yeah about
the athletes look at how gorgeous
Russell Karl is unbelievable just about
how he's he didn't stutter once
[Music]
this is like maybe one of the best I
intend top 10 sets I've ever seen
now this is the part where he roasted
people by the way by the way he wrote it
as hard as any volunteer you reinforce
the idea that his girl I hope so damn
yeah that's crazy
damn I'm 62 years old I know I love that
he's 10 years old I know so brightly
you've seen every service football have
you ever watched a football game uh yeah
man you know the sport yeah I do
I knew that was Joe Namath so how the
[ __ ] well you know what a quarterback
yeah what about tighten y'all up the
little the quarterback you looking for
right right
all right in the college this is amazing
hold on almost so what did you cut it
out we're gonna go anyway all right
let's go the next thing all right quick
ones here a comedian our boy I met IMed
he makes that Middle East joke yeah I
had Captain Brian's Brian's my buddy
Brian Pina and then and apparently he
said all that Ahmed Ahmed says how many
Middle Eastern here couple races in
their hands and he said something like
all right well we play for you here yeah
this is it's really nothing at all but
the guy that damn it it's such politics
one I told Brian yes I don't hear the
club I said it's good publicity focus
some Tommy
[Music]
tell a joke that's how I said that's a
good joke I'm here
so soda so as a friend of Ahmed's for 20
years he's a [ __ ] great guy and and
that person who called 9-1-1 is just an
ignorant everyone thinks he's in it you
guys gonna find somebody but it's a no
reflection on Brian
Brian's club or Ahmed Ahmed and it's
just it's not even shouldn't even
newsworthy but some dummy called 9-1-1
and he was i don't think it's very nice
and i don't think it's a newsworthy
because of the guy being an idiot
exactly yeah that's what goes back to
what we were saying is any any [ __ ]
yeah all right you guys good yeah all
right well guys come see me in Orlando
this weekend and if you're a fan of mine
and if you're in Orlando fly to Edmonton
high and don't go to his no Indianapolis
I'm gonna be at the funny bone June 6th
7th and 8th and I'm Brendon and I'll be
in Las Vegas you guys I just found I'm
gonna be in Tempe Arizona I think the
20th 21st and seventh no I changed that
oh and we just found I changed the date
to a week earlier I'm not gonna be in
Tempe the 27th I gotta have and also
congratulations to Brian he's gonna be
in a dad again a new dad man you got
some come on somebody pregnant she's a
50 year old housewife that's already
married
so congratulations Ben what's going on
okay man he checked out all right bye
thanks Chris and a reminder this Friday
watch I think you'd be so or you'd be
surprised
Showtime 7:00 p.m. on Friday Brendan
Schaub one-hour special school use a
coat promo code shop SC
eh-eh you be and you will get 30 days of
free Showtime watch it anyway notice
that Brian missed up one of his best
friend's titles on the show and it's all
good but you'd be surprised a problem I
think you'd be surprised
okay well watch it alright